it distracts the learner from the main
goal which is to get
lots of exposure to the language steve
coffin here
and today you know i want to talk about
grammar how important is grammar
and i'm going to talk about grammar in
the context of
all of the details of languages that
we learn in school how effective is it
to teach these details
if the ultimate goal is to become fluent
in a language
now remember if you enjoy these videos
please
subscribe you can click on the bell for
notifications by the way you'll notice
that i have my link
t-shirt on i just happened to find that
in the closet when i was getting dressed
this morning
um at any rate so you know details
one of the things that struck me in
manfred spitzer's book and i often refer
to it
is that when he explains that the brain
our brains
and all the brains the process of
learning is the same there are no
people with brains that learn better
this way or that way our brains learn
the same
the same way we have our likes and
dislikes but the process of learning is
the same
and the brains are better our brains
are better at forming patterns and
recognizing patterns
and not so good at retaining detail
so that the details that we learn that
we keep somewhere in our short-term
memory we lose them
but over time the brain starts to
recognize a pattern
and that's very much in my view the
process by which we learn languages
so you know if you sort of spell out
like grammar
grammar basically describes usage so
since
languages evolve over time sounds in
languages evolve over time
you know usage patterns evolve over time
so
the grammar which describes the usage
will evolve
over time so how useful is it to attempt
to teach
people how the lang what what the rules
of usage
are before the learner has had enough
experience with the language i think
it's not that useful
and at least in our school system in
canada where they
teach french they teach grammar they
teach grammar because
it's something they can easily test the
learners on
and some learners got 8 out of 10 and
some got six out of ten so
learner a with eight out of ten is
better than learner b
with six out of ten but that doesn't
necessarily mean
that at the end of the day learner a is
going to be better
at speaking than learner b it may mean
that but it's not
obvious and there are many cases where
learner b who maybe is exposed more to
the language maybe
had comes from you know a country where
the language is spoken he hears the
language at home but he speaks it
incorrectly from a grammatical point of
view and so he does poorly on the test
but he understands and he communicates
and there are many examples like that
so my feeling on grammar and other
details of the language is that they can
be introduced
at any time they should be introduced
when the learner is
interested in them it's uh it's true
that
many of the patterns in the language you
know are not
noticed when we hear even hearing the
language over and over again we don't
notice certain niceties of pronunciation
we don't notice that certain syllables
aren't stressed
we don't notice you know the whatever it
might be
third person singular in english of the
present tense
uh it it takes
ns whereas the other forms of the verb
don't we don't notice these things so
sometimes it can be useful to point
these things out therefore
i think it's useful to have a reference
grammar and every language that i have
learned
i have tried to get a hold of a grammar
as small as possible
with no exercises no drills just
what happens in the language and a bunch
of examples
and so i look at that and i see the
examples and it's
just helping my brain get used to
how the language works the patterns in
the language
and this approach i think is the same
for other details of the language for
example pronunciation
up front when it is explained to you
using international phonetic
the international phonetic alphabet that
this sound is pronounced
this way i don't personally find that
very useful
i find that with the availability of
audio today text to speech i can hear
how it's pronounced
but it is possible that three months
later
having listened to the language many
many times
i still don't notice that a certain
vowel is pronounced a certain way
or i don't notice that the stress is a
certain way
or in the case of pitch accent that it's
this way rather than that way
and so at that time later on to help us
notice things that might have passed us
by
it's useful to refer to these
explanations
but there is far too much emphasis
placed placed on these
these explanations or these details of a
language
with the intention of testing people on
these details and the result
is normally not very good because it
distracts the learner
from the main goal which is to get lots
of exposure to the language
lots of listening lots of reading and as
krashen says
in an environment that is low stress
that is enjoyable
and if you do that and if you trust your
brain
a lot of these things will be acquired
naturally and therefore you needn't be
tested on if the goal is comprehension
they don't even need to test you on your
comprehension
even if you misunderstand something the
fact that you are putting in the time
listening and reading will eventually
enable your brain to get used to the
language
so in my approach to language learning i
want to
sort of de-emphasize the sort of details
the grammar
the other specific explanations because
our brains are not
as good at dealing with these
explanations
and rather encourage people to find ways
to enjoy the language
listen to the language don't worry about
what you don't understand don't worry
about the mistakes that you make
if you continue to expose yourself to
the language
you will gradually get better and when
you are interested and genuinely curious
about specific details you can look them
up and it's never been easier to look
them up
but but don't get yourself a thick
grammar book like this get yourself the
thinnest possible grammar book
which explains what's happened in the
language with examples
without exercises without drills and go
over it
regularly don't try and block learn the
conjugation table of a specific verb
just look it over forget it look it over
recognize you're going to forget it and
go back there and eventually over time
that activity looking things up grammar
rules whatever
which are limited unlike the amount of
words we have to learn which is almost
unlimited the grammar rules are actually
quite limited
and if you keep on flipping through a
sort of a thin grammar book
you will eventually get a very good
overview of what happens in the language
and when you combine that with lots of
listening and reading you're going to
get better and better at the language
rather than trying to fight the rules of
grammar
up front so that's my take on grammar
and
i've covered this subject before and
i'll leave a few other
videos on the same subject bye for now